you were one of the first to identify
design as important in business you know
that's widely accepted now but how much
is lip service and how much our business
is really paying attention to it I think
it's a mix of both I see some leading
businesses really adopting design to
make their strategies more creative
their product lineups more compelling
some obvious they are doing the lip
service thing but no companies like Lego
and PNG and Steelcase I see them doing
great things with design so you're
speaking with Tim Braun the CEO of IDEO
a famous design firm here in Silicon
Valley talk about some of the work
you're doing with audio well what what
Tim Braun and I have been trying to do
for the last decade is take design away
from a strictly product design to design
of more complicated things design a
business strategy design of large system
change and I think that's where there's
there's the greatest promise for design
we're really interested in how do you
how do you use design principles to
create better government policy for
example how to overcome gridlock in
Washington with with design so that's
the sort of thing we're working on these
days when we think about designing
products we usually think about it as a
talent right and intuitive talent it's
the Johnny Ives of the world that know
how to do it so when you talk about
designing strategy how much is talent
and how much a skill that can be learned
I think it's mainly skill that can be
learned I mean and I think Johnny Ives
and Tim Brown would would both say that
that they would say I'm not sure that
I'm a great design born a great designer
but I've just worked at it for years and
years it's the 10,000 hours thing and
and so III think there are a lot of
people who just don't think they're
creative and I I don't think there's any
non creative person out there so you
wrote you co-wrote a hit business book
with AG Lafley recently planed to win
maybe talked a little bit about how
design thinking around strategy comes
into play at a company like Procter &
Gamble well this is a big thrust of a
G's when he took over as CEO first in
2000 he said we're gonna make design a
key to our competitive success and he
created created a design function but
this wonderful woman Claudia Koch chica
and in charge of it and a lot of the
great things they they did in
that era like the the total revamp of
oil of olay turning it from a small
boring business into a two and a half
billion dollar juggernaut that was all
based on these design principles that he
brought to the company who are the other
success stories when it comes to
designing business strategy oh I really
like Lego I do a bunch of work with Lego
what a great a great company and things
like the friends line four four four
girls were I think a great kind of
product of their their thinking about
design Steelcase the office furniture
company is is terrific as well they're
now in designing designing environment
you know how do we design design the
workplace to be to help the foster more
of productivity and happiness in the
workers those be a couple so you had a
pretty interesting article in the
Harvard Business Review recently and
talked about kind of fear-based strategy
where companies try to predict the
future in react talk a little bit about
the mistakes companies make as they
strategize for the future yeah I think
most companies see strategy as an
analytical exercise and it arose out of
that that that world the early people in
strategy were very analytically oriented
number crunchers and i think it's much
more of a creative process where where
if you just take the data from the past
and extrapolate it forward you're not
gonna do anything in trying to predict
the future it's impossible yeah that's
right I know and I actually think you
gotta make the future and I think
everybody like Steve Jobs I liked him
too I mean he wasn't willing to
extrapolate the past he said we can make
the future and and I think that's where
greatness comes for for companies not
just accepting whatever the industry is
doing we're gonna do that too but rather
than saying no no here's a future we can
create so you're not just predicting
something random you are actively
creating it and I think design has a
whole lot to do with how you can think
about designing a future that you'd like
to your company to go into